it's cake week here at the show and we
have someone that we're gonna talk to
right now
and i'm very excited um mckayla is here
and she is um a nurse
in the public health circuit of the
coven 19 response team in seattle
and she uses her love of baking to raise
money for
racial justice please welcome michaela
banks hi michaela
oh wow hi drew barrymore hi ross
hi hi so listen i grew up right up there
near seattle so i'm so
i'm so inspired by what you're doing
this is great
yeah oh that's hungry what inspired you
you auction off your cakes
and please explain yeah
so all of this started i love that cakes
and sweet treats are so disarming
and so when we talk about racial justice
it kind of grounds us to this place of
seeking justice for people seeking
rightness for people is sweet it's
lovely
and even holding accountable the parts
of myself that cause harm that's hard
but it's beautiful
and so there's this uh sentiment about
toni morrison so dr clara griffin said
and the pieces i am documentary
toni morrison said what can i do where i
am and so as i was reflecting on that i
thought one of the things
i have to give is a baking habit so i
started
auctioning off my first cake for equal
justice initiative
and the heart behind all of this the
whole time has been how can we
dive deeper into learning what are the
issues what's going on
and then what are people already doing
about it the work has been happening
let's follow in the lead of the heroes
in the streets and the courtrooms and
the classrooms
and so enjoy a cake while really
giving of ourselves to support what's
important look kayla
we love what you are doing and what you
and your cakes represent
is so meaningful i'm going to be
thinking about that tony morrison quote
too
yeah do what you can where you are i
will carry that
with us in honor of your bringing that
into
a light for us and ross and i would love
to bid
five thousand dollars to you and donate
it towards the naacp
a charity we understand is very close
yes
keep up that great work we applaud you
michaela thank you for coming on the
show and shining a light and obviously
if you go to the drewberrymart show.com
michaela's work her website her
instagram everything will be on there if
you would like to join in this as well
thank you michaela
[Music]